President Trump is condemning the leak
of a cruel common by one of his aides
about Senator John McCain according to a
White House source Kelly Sadler said
McCain's opposition to the president's
CIA nominee didn't matter because the
senator is dying the president
complained on Twitter that quote leakers
are traitors and cowards Nancy Cordes is
on Capitol Hill Nancy good morning good
morning and now a number of Republican
lawmakers are calling on the White House
and this particular staffer to publicly
apologize for those comments about John
McCain but President Trump by his own
admission has never been big on public
apologies and his team appears
determined to follow his lead if it were
me I would apologize
Louisiana's John Kennedy and several of
his colleagues are urging White House
communications aide Kelly Sadler to
issue a public maiya culpa I don't know
whether she's stupid or not but she sure
made a bad decision Sadler was in a
White House meeting last week when John
McCain's opposition to CIA nominee Gina
Haspel came up according to a White
House source Sadler joked about the 81
year old senator who is battling brain
cancer quote it doesn't matter
he's dying anyway colleagues leaked her
comments to reporters it's going to be
dealt with and has been dealt with
internally deputy White House press
secretary Raj Shah deflected questions
about Sadler's comments instead focusing
on the leaks that creates a very
difficult work environment I think
anybody who works anywhere it could
recognize that I said everything I
really had to say on Friday
McCain's daughter Megan co-host of the
daytime talk show the view said the
White House shouldn't be surprised if
you're working in the White House you
should expect everything you're saying
in any context to be leaked Republican
strategist Matt slap whose wife works in
the White House came to Sadler's defense
she said character to immediately call
to apologize but she's also a little bit
of a victim here but McCain occupies a
special place in the Senate one thing
about our colleague John McCain hmm
you'd rather be on his side than not and
some Republicans say the best way to
move past this would be to quote show
some respect and apologize this culture
of
contempt is not healthy for anybody
Sadler did apologize personally to Megan
McCain and told her according to our
sources that she would be making a
public apology so far that hasn't
happened
Kellyanne Conway a White House adviser
did indicate last night that there might
be some staffing changes at the White
House gale as a result of these leaks
all right Nancy thank you very much you
know what's interesting to me is that
people are joining this debate and
keeping going because it's a debate
about civility that's right it's how we
talk about one another especially at
some of the most vulnerable moments this
is not politics this is a moment that
demands civility and when you double
down on something that people find so
egregious it just continues and
continues in Cubao 2-story days later
because of that and you know inside the
White House the president is concerned
about leaks there are two ways to stop
leaks you guys are crackdown on them
where you set an example of public
behavior so everybody says I don't want
to leak because I don't want to merge a
White House that is holding that kind of
standard and so this is a situation
where you know the standard is that
question here and it is going to keep
going on I also wonder now too if the
apology does come will you feel it
sincere since you had to be beaten to do
it yeah but the story still continues
remember Gail the heart here is a man
who has a very serious it's another
human being who is ill and and facing a
very tough road I mean that's where that
can get lost here too that's what
everybody's thinking about Nancy we
thank you